so Chuck yes I brought you here today
for lunch
clearly you pay so just to show the
difference between an average full moon
right and what people are calling the
super moon soup
this being New York City right pizza is
the best sort of circular object to
reference yes and it kind of looks like
a moon like watching yeah so I went up
to the front and I said when Ray's
famous Ray's Pizza right and I said I
please like a 15 inch pizza right which
is here and a 16 inch pizza right which
is here and then they went who is this I
said look we got we I can do this we got
this okay right so point being the
average size of the full moon on the sky
right is to a 15 inch pizza what the
super moon is to a 16 inch rates so what
you see normally okay this is the run
average moon is closer and closer
sometimes far away and that change in
difference when it's closer it's a
little bigger looks a little bigger
right it was farther it looks a little
small it's it's an oval orbit around the
Earth it's not a perfect circle right
there's a perfect circle be the same
size all the time okay
it can be at any phase at any of these
distances okay you can have a really big
Crescent right all right or a big
Halfmoon there's nobody can't nobody
know because super super Crescent oh you
could say that but no one is okay we've
somehow fantasized about the full moon
so I'm just trying to show you the
difference between the two right I want
to take the 15 inch pizza after we
measured it what are you just excuse me
this is very science Oh God okay this is
for science all right this next science
Oh Lord Jesus he is killing this people
so really it's just for very got a
little teeny bit bit like that all the
way around average full moon right super
moon so if that half inch right it's
super to you right on his pizza yeah
then call the moon what the hell you
want but in a pizza shop nobody hears
calling this one super right you know
coming to give me a super pizza and then
you make a half inch bigger all around
right half inch and a half inch makes an
inch that's all I'm saying
Chuck uh-oh oh it's okay a super moon is
a half inch bigger than a regular moon
now why you get to cut the pizza ah oh
man I'm hungry I'll tell you what no
matter what this moon is delicious yeah
okay okay let's eat some moon is eat
some moon baby I don't sound good
[Laughter]
you